Doesn't even want to be in the clip. All right, don't even want
to be in the clip. He wants to get the What do What do you think
would be worse? Like selling our secrets to Israel or selling
our secrets to China? >> It's Inglourious Basterds and
he's basically GOING LIKE, "WHO WANTS TO GO NEXT? ANYBODY WANT
TO GO NEXT?"
SO, WE'RE GOING TO WATCH from here. This is around the timing
of the conversation. So, they're going to have a conversation
about who would you vote
John Fetterman or Hasan [__] Now, this should be
Cuz for all you say about Hasan [__] he's not an
elected Democrat.
And I can't think of an elected Democrat who works harder against
the interests of the Democratic Party than John
Hutch already Hutch is already locked in. I love it. Hutch is
already totally locked in. Looks like he's staring down the barrel
of a gun as we speak. He's a locked in. I need to get there.
I need to get there with him, okay? I'm very interested in IRI's
thoughts on John Fetterman throwing Democrats under the bus on
Fox News. But I can only look at the results. It may be the stroke
had something to do with it. Maybe he just doubled down, tripled
down, quadrupled down on the Israel stuff. Maybe there's some
other reason for why he's talking every 2 seconds. Remember,
Fetterman was the one Democratic vote for Pam Bondi. For Pam
Bondi. Why are any Democrats voting for a Republican candidate?
I think there was another Democrat from He's pretty isolated
though, you know? He doesn't have like a ton of institutional
support, right? I mean, he feels like he's off on his own little
island and he's not going to survive a primary. So, that's going
to be like the process playing out and sort self-correcting,
right? No, I absolutely and I think that that's good, Hutch.
And I think that you're right. I think that it shows that there's
a self-correction mechanism that there are Democrats who are
keeping an eye on our elected officials. All I'm trying to say
is to put in perspective that Democrats have a I don't know,
a series of attributes and aspects and policy positions and some
to me are more offensive than others and I consider what Fetterman
is doing and the Fetterman nation the Fetterman types, these
kind of enlightened oh, my my party sucks. I just find that to
be odious and reprehensible. And maybe I'm dumb but that offends
me more than like the the dead-ender Hasan types, but it does.
Especially when they're talking. >> He was on Fox News
the other day and he said that the the leader of the Democratic
Party is Trump Derangement Syndrome and that that's not helping.
>> That's not helping, man. >> That's kind of a totally
insane thing to do. But that's the dope. You should push back
on Hasan [__] I I hate the Crimea stuff. I will note
though that it's a little weird for people to be like my line
my red line in the sand is his comments on Crimea and then like
complain about red lines being drawn on Israel. Like if they're
if it's like a weird thing to put in a line for some sort of
foreign conflict vis-a-vis like uh just as a principle matter
to be a dead-ender when it comes to and listen I totally support
Ukraine continuing to fund Ukraine. I think that Russia's invasion
is completely reprehensible. We should be fighting against Russia,
etc. But just be consistent about it. And if you're going to
have a dead-end position on foreign conflicts, I don't think
that in principle I don't really see a reason that be so offended
by drawing a red line in one and not the other. I don't know.
Most of the people that I've seen drawing a red line about Hasan
is for his other rhetoric and I think just the fact that he said
what he said about Crimea just illustrates that he's not consistent
on his anti-imperialism anti-war position. He's only anti-imperial
anti-imperial
I too there's so many ways you could attack this. But like
like the lens the imperial anti-imperialist imperialist lens
is letting Ukraine be seized by the the global hegemon. That's
like that's the lens he's looking at it through. If if you want
to use that lens, that's like the one lens you probably can't
criticize this through. Right? I And yeah, I just he doesn't
even support Russia. I don't know.
I feel like you could defend it through that lens if you wanted
to. No, but it's you know vis-a-vis the West. 100% yeah.
Yeah, no. His position sucks. We got we got it we got a chat
from
Everyone, Fetterman or Hasan, who are you voting for in 2028?
Fetterman or
There we go. Everyone, Fetterman or Hassan, who are you voting
for in 2028? Fetterman or Hassan? Hassan or Fetterman? I'm voting
I'm voting Fetterman.
Oh, dude. Pisco Pisco must just feast if if dude.
What? I can just imagine Pisco feasts off of this. Like why would
they Why would you even say this? It's It can only be I think
Hassan is like hiding his You have to do the Oh, he's hiding
his power level. He's actually a
And that bison is so many other things. It's very
very goofy. We're You guys are insane. You guys are I mean the
No, not at all. Hassan is Hassan is against the save America.
He's anti-democracy. Fetterman's stupid and awful, but you know,
I don't think he's >> Oh, wait. 2028. Fetterman or Hassan?
Hassan or Fetterman? I'm voting Fetterman. I'm voting Fetterman.
You guys are You guys are insane. You guys are I mean the No,
not at all. Hassan is Hassan is against the save America. He's
anti-democracy. Fetterman's stupid and awful, but you know, I
don't think he's going to try to like destroy the American system.
I think that that's crazy, but >> We already We already
talked about this though, Pisco. Like what would you feel confident
that he would not go to China and give up our secrets?
I have no view on that he's going to I don't know that he's a
Chinese spy. Do you have the access to that? Do you think he's
going to No, you have to you have to you have to you have to
you have to you have to you have to you have to you have to you
have to you have to you have to you have to you have to you have
>> definitely sympathetic to China. Yes, he's definitely
sympathetic to China.
Do you think that Fetterman is going to sell secrets to Israel?
Is Is Fetterman going to sell secrets to Israel?
So, we we watched this clip earlier. Yes, that is the question.
If they point out selling secrets to China is such a risk for
Hassan, yeah, what do you think Fetterman's not going to sell
secrets to Israel? Do you think Uh, you would give them for free?
Just wait. Just wait cuz the response to this will floor you,
okay?
He's the biggest Israel simp I've ever
Well, technically Israel's a partner, but I'm saying like, you
know, we Israel shouldn't be Why does that help us selling secrets
to them? Why does that help? be a partner. This is crazy. I I
No, I I I I doesn't even want to be in the clip. I I don't even
want to be in the clip. He wants to get the out. You know, we
didn't shouldn't be a partner. This is crazy.
You know what? I understand that, but I'm just saying strategically
that it's like worse What do you What do you think would be worse?
Like selling our secrets to Israel or selling our secrets to
I'm not sure that anyone in the books I
There's no way they're going to try Either one's totally disqualifying.
By the way, like I who would I rather the secrets end up in the
hands of?
Um, in in military in the case of military secrets, Israel. In
the case of some other secrets, it could be that like I don't
think China would be worse than Israel. They'd probably be about
equal. I can't think of a situation where Israel would be worse
than China.
But either way, if they end up in Israel's hands, they're going
to a bunch of other countries, too. Right right Right now, right
now I think that currently it would be worse to sell secrets
to China.
Currently, I think it's worse to sell secrets to China 100%,
but if if you ask me in terms of the totality of policies in
this hypothetical, I would I would pick Hassan any any day of
the week. Fetterman is a MAGA sellout. He is a MAGA sell The
whole point of he would sell secrets to another country is it's
meant to be like disqualifying. I wouldn't vote for this person.
They both have something totally disqualifying about them. >> out.
He's saying every Democrat has Trump Derangement Syndrome. He's
voting for Republican MAGA bills. He's against the Save America
Act. He can't be full
He's in favor of the Laken Riley Act. He's in favor of funding
ICE and DHS. He's in favor Who was Raphael Warnock? Okay, and
that's bad and Ossoff gets points deducted from that. He's not
in my S tier. He's in my A B tier because of what he did there
and he should apologize for that [__] But I have
no tolerance for MAGA whatsoever, MAGA sympathies whatsoever,
and frankly, I think this discourse is and I'm not going to engage
in it anymore on like the coalition building non-coalition. I
think it's stupid as but yeah, I think Fetterman sucks and I
think that people who for example who say that like Trump isn't
that bad or that I just it's such again it's such bad optics
to go well Israel's our ally, maybe it's not so bad. And I thought
Hutch maybe wasn't making that argument for a second, but he
was. Israel's not as bad to sell secrets to? No, anybody selling
secrets of your country to anyone else, if you suspect that that's
totally disqualifying. Never accept that as a bar. What?
And I think that people who for example who say that like Trump
isn't that bad or that like the party needs to stop being so
up up in arms about Trump when he's giving these like insane
takes part of this illegal war. Fetterman is supporting the illegal
war in Iran. This is That's obviously yeah, all of dude, the
entire Trump derangement syndrome thing. Doing that on Fox News
that's
cataclysmic. That should be totally
Could you imagine if bro, these people say they can't vote for
Hassan or they don't trust Hassan because he said you know, I
don't even think Kamala's better on Israel. One little cut out
where he was like I'm not even convinced Kamala would be better
here.
And they're like up they're literally all over Hassan for that.
That's crazy. >> worst policies we've ever done. It's an
affront to the Constitution. It's an affront to everything that
he was supposed to stand for from the ideological position on
new no new wars. Hassan wouldn't get into get us into that. And
that is like a concrete >> on withdrawing from NATO, he'd
sell us out to China. He'd do a lot worse than >> is saying
he's going to get us out of NATO. This is insane. Trump Trump
is anti-NATO. of MAGA. Like he's he's he's defending These are
all hypotheticals and you don't know that that would be the case.
You literally don't know that that would be the case. I'm telling
you like in my and listen, I I could have the wrong read.
If you just take Hassan's love for China, shirt looks like that
on the surface. But I assume he would pass certain things to
even be an option for president. And I assume that he understands
that selling out your country is the worst thing you can do.
You know what I'm saying? I My concern would be him pulling back
from the South China Sea, from the island chain strategy. That
would be a a reasonable concern. Saying he's going to sell secrets
to China or What is the other thing So he feels that leave NATO?
I don't know that he would do that. I actually don't think he
would leave NATO. Fetterman is supporting the Fetterman is supporting
the alleged president in this conduct, which is fracturing NATO
and showing NATO to be toothless. Unfortunately, unfortunately,
and and it's causing Trump to break from NATO and put pressure
on our NATO allies. I mean, anyone who's supporting this war
this It should be a line in the sand. The mere fact that I have
to argue like this is an illegal war. It is [__]
up American foreign policy interests. It is going to be spend
a lot of billions of dollars, and I don't understand how we can
Anyone who supports it That's like one of the worst things you
can do. But, you There's public perception of the funding as
well, and a lot of people out there may think that if you're
voting no on supplemental funds, you're abandoning our troops.
That may be a big reason why some of these guys are voting no.
Are voting for it? That's not Fetterman. Fetterman is cheerleading
the war. So, I mean, we can talk about like the Why are you laughing?
Is that You don't believe that? Fetterman is true Is Fetterman
cheerleading the war, yes or no? I have not seen his thoughts
on the war. I'll take your word for it that he is and I agree
he's misstepping. But, I'm just
Like, IRI is in such a crazy place right now. IRI would have
you believe that there's something John Fetterman or any other
congressperson has said publicly that he is not seen. Literally,
all he does is watch C-SPAN all day. THERE'S NO SHOT HE MISSED
THIS. Is there?
What What has IRI ever been unaware of a statement from a from
a congressperson? I've never seen that before. I've never seen
him make that argument before my entire life. Oh, I've never
seen this congressperson say this. He's aware of all of this
all the time. I'm saying in general, somebody like Jared Golden
or uh you know, any moderate Dem I think would vote for it possibly
because their district believes it it would be abandoning the
troops who at that moment if we don't. And and that is and that
is because this this war should be a litmus test. I'm not saying
that you shouldn't vote for a Democrat who like given the choice
between Fetterman and a die in the wool met like like mega person
that's you know, further even mega. I obviously would pick Fetterman
over that. But this war the policies related I stand private
property. I stand Lennon who like genocided the Kulaks. Like
this is not like I think you're not weighing the all totality
of the worst things he >> I am. Of course I am. And of
course I mean we're doing the same thing with with with the Epstein
hypothetical and all this stuff and like the checks. I'm not
assuming he's going to be able to achieve those aims and given
Okay. Well so now you're making a guardrails argument where >> a
guard Guardrails. It's Okay. So when I was when someone asks
you who you're going to vote for for president so I put in any
hypothetical, you're assuming total dictatorial power, right?
That's what you're assuming when you're asked that question.
Oh, right. The other thing is hold on. That is a good point.
That Fetterman's basically cut against all of the things he ran
on. That Fetterman has like lied about essentially everything
he ran on.
I forgot about that. No, I'm assuming that this person's power
is going to be worse for the country if they can shift the over
Who is hiding their power level more? Fetterman or Hassan? It's
definitely Fetterman, right? >> window towards more of
their politics. I think that's fundamentally worse. >> you
a question. When when you someone asks you if in a hypothetical
you choose one president over another, are you assuming complete
and total dictatorial power? Yes or no? Basically, because I'm
assuming the worst. Yeah. Okay. All right. So that's that is
not how when I ask the question and when that that question is
asked to me, someone just scoffed. So when you're asked the question,
who would you vote for president? Are you assuming the normal
constraints on a president or you assuming complete and total
absolute
Are you asking me or whoever scoffed? Whoever scoffed. I mean
there was a hot guy Dude, Piscatella
club. He he's literally
These are three German soldiers and he's the bear, okay? It's
It's Inglourious Basterds and he's basically GOING LIKE, "WHO
WANTS TO GO NEXT? ANYBODY WANT TO GO NEXT?" HE'S just carrying
this bat around like a total psycho right now. Everybody in the
room is like, "Holy shit." He's totally correct. He should be
doing it. You should HAVE YOUR SKULL CAVED IN. METAPHORICALLY,
METAPHORICALLY, METAPHORICALLY, metaphorically in this case.
We're saying crazy [__] you choose one president
over another, are you assuming complete and total dictatorial
power, yes or no? Basically, because I'm assuming the worst,
yeah. Okay. All right. So, that's That is not how when I ask
the question and when that question is I think I think that was
IRI. I don't think anyone actually scoffed. I think IRI was smiling,
but I think he just breathed into his >> That to me. Someone
just scoffed. So, when you're >> I think I think he just
breathed into the Either him or Hutch, I think they just breathed
into the mic a little bit. I don't think it was actually a scoff.
>> ask the question, who would you vote for president?
Are you assuming >> You got this No, who scoffed? Who the
[__] scoffed? Who the [__] scoffed? >> the
normal constraints on a president, or are you assuming complete
and total absolute authority? Are you asking me or whoever scoffed?
Whoever scoffed. I mean, there was a Hutch, IRI. I mean, do you
really assume when someone asks you the question about a president
this is peacego. Would you vote for Donald Trump if you thought
he could get nothing done versus Fetterman, who you think would
be worse and could get the war in Iran passed? Like, if you thought
that might happen, maybe, but that's not how I operate when I'm
voting for someone. I'm like, "Damn, I'm I don't want this >> You
don't think about what they could >> I think the guardrails
could keep them in Like, I would have thought the guardrails
would have kept Trump >> consider what they could do? What
What their What they could do? You don't consider that? Absolutely
consider what they could do, but I also consider, "Hey, there
are a bunch of norms being violated that I never thought might
be broken in my lifetime, and I'm not going to risk the person
who's saying the worst things." >> Fetterman abides it.
Fetterman abides >> Ho- Hold on, people. >> Fetterman
abides ice abuses and constitutional disgusting conduct. And
so, he's on all fours. I am the scoffer, okay? I scoff because
of the ridiculousness of Fetterman, not your >> Oh, he
did scoff. HE AD- HE ADMITS TO
HE ADMITS TO SCOFFING. OH MY GOD, I thought he just breathed
into the mic. I was I was trying to be nice. >> That's
I'm not I'm not trying to give you a hard time. I'm I'm not I
agree that Fetterman is doing some ridiculous things right now.
And I'm just laughing at how absurd he is, like saying Dude,
Hutch is so nervous. Hutch is having flashbacks to the conversations
he had with Pisco, like in the moment. >> Scuffer, okay.
I scoffed at the ridiculousness. That's not your point.
That's I'm not I'm not trying to give you a hard time. I'm I'm
not I agree that Fetterman is doing some ridiculous things right
now. And I'm just laughing at how absurd he is, like saying that
we have Trump Derangement Syndrome on our side. So, I agree with
you that he's misstepping. I'm just trying to make an argument
for the other moderates who may end up voting for something like
this or supporting it. I don't think Fetterman's putting on a
show. I just think he is this guy. Like I think he genuinely
I think he genuinely believes these things. And, you know, he
I think he managed to hide a lot of that from the voters when
he was running. And now the voters can see
Oh, I disagree with that. Uh well, I don't know. I mean, you
he's hiding anything. I think Israel kind of broke his brain
for whatever reason. I don't know. It happened to a lot of people
on the other side of the issue, too, where they're like, you
know, it's it's Yeah, that's the problem. Go down. It's broke
a lot of people's brains. It's anti-Semitic to suggest that Mossad
used to stroke gun on John Fetterman's guy. And I will not accept
Well, okay, but real quick, Pisco, you're like, oh well, he supports
weakening NATO because in supporting this war and Trump's rhetoric
on it that is like, hey, NATO, you're not helping us and maybe
he even wants to do like the Iraq thing, or invoke Article 5
to get NATO allies to help us in the Strait of Hormuz. John Fetterman
is still unequivocally pro-NATO. Hassan is unequivocally anti-NATO,
and like almost worse than Trump is. And so, like the idea that
like, oh well, I I'm going to weigh these things equally because
of his tacit support for the war in Iran, I think is really burying
the lead of one of these people wants to dismantle this entire
thing and thinks it's a force for evil. And the other person
unequivocally supports it, but might be undermining it by supporting
Trump's war. >> He He genuinely He genuinely believes He
genuinely believes that America is the most evil country that
has ever existed in the face of the planet. When he talks to
like young lefty audiences, he will tell them you're in the belly
of the beast. I mean like that He genuinely believes that. He
believes that the Republican Party is the most evil institution
on the planet. And he believes the Democratic Party is the second
most >> Hassan is bad. Hassan has Hassan has really, really
bad beliefs. He's figured it out. He's figured it out. Hassan
is
Hassan is bad. Cuz Cuz I would not pick Hassan would not even
be my my on my top 10,000 list of candidates that I would you
know, I would I'd probably just choose a random Democrat. But
I think the point I'm trying to make is that I'd pick a random
Democratic person over Hassan. I think the point that IRI and
Soy Pal are trying to make is that, you know,
someone like Fetterman can vote with Democrats like well over
90% of the time and have really bad takes, but that's not quite
as bad as But I think the point I'm trying to make is that I'd
pick a random Democratic person over Hassan. I think the point
that IRI and Soy Pal are trying to make is that, you know,
someone like Fetterman can vote with Democrats like well over
90% of the time and have really bad takes. That's not quite as
bad as somebody who is genuinely invested in like the downfall
of America as it currently is.
Okay, I disagree that Fetterman is not a devoted, at least in
result, to the downfall. If Hassan was like devoted to the downfall
of America, why would he be approaching it this way?
Why would he be speaking aspirationally talking about what he
wants that's good for the American people? I just Isn't there
an easier like Isn't it literally just what
the data centers are vulnerable? Isn't that the path you take
if you just genuinely want the downfall of America?
I just don't get it. It feels weird. >> fall of America
as it is. You say that like the he's ideologically committed
to the downfall of America. You say, "What?" What do you say,
"What?" TO?
THIS GUY'S so psychotic. I love it. I love it. Where was this
guy? Where was this guy? Don't elbows. >> disagree that
Fetterman is not a devoted, at least in result, to the downfall
of America as it is. You say that like the he's ideologically
committed to the downfall of America. You say, "What?" What did
you say, "What?" to? What What's the what
Um I love it cuz Hutch needs this. Hutch needs to have these
elbows thrown in his face cuz he does things that are elbows
to other people and then he goes and cries when it actually is
thrown back at him. Like I promise you we're going to get the
same thing where and I Trust me, this will happen. This absolutely
happen. Somebody's going to go "Pisco's being mad to Hutch again.
Destiny, go say something about it." And I guess we're going
to see I would love to see that because at that
how does Destiny even disagree with that? This guy's out there.
He votes for Pan Body. He is straight up saying, "Well, the leader
of the Democratic Party is tedious."
How could you flip so much on your beliefs that you flip on that?
That's got to be a core thing. Trump is bad. That's got to be
a core thing. No? I don't know what position.
We'll see.
No, I'm asking what What is the what position? You said, "What?"
What was so ridiculous? that John Fetterman is as What is the
what position? No, no, no. I'm asking you the question. Do you
think that John Fetterman is as invested as Hasan [__]
in the downfall of
I said that in result that Fetterman's actions would contribute
more to the downfall of America than someone who's than Hasan
to the I absolutely do.
Again, the entire reason that you guys don't like Hasan is because
Hasan is a threat to democracy. John Fetterman is doing pro-Trump
rhetoric from within the Democratic Party. What is a bigger threat
to democracy? Hasan [__] or John Fetterman? Answer
the question. Yes or no. I formulate any yes or no, Pisco, but
then ask it again. >> Somebody's ideologically committed
Ask it again. That's my answer. In result How? How could you
possibly How could you possibly believe that? I think So, I I
this war, the Iran war, is contributing to the decline of America
in a geostrategic way in a way that we've like not seen before.
And so number one, support for this war from an internal constitutional
perspective, from a geostrategic interest, this has helped Iran,
weakened America, weakened our alliances with our with our actual
friends, like the the Five Eyes with Canada, with Australia,
led to massive gains for Russia. Absolutely massive gains. He's
taken sanctions off of Russian oil.
Right? All of EU >> keep going down the line. Yes. >> And
so when I tell you that this war, this war is contributing to
the downfall of America
that declaring this war will lead to the death and destruction
of significantly more Ukrainian soldiers and civilians than would
have happened otherwise. Or just total capitulation on Ukraine's
part. I believe it. I think that that's true. Regardless of >> of
his support with Iran versus someone who fundamentally believes
we should pull out of NATO, that US aid is like a CIA front,
that we should dismantle anyway, we should capitulate to China.
This These are not
Wait, does Hassan really believe that you should pull out of
NATO? When Trump says we should pull out of NATO, Hassan goes,
"Yeah, that's awesome. We should get out of NATO NATO." Is that
a thing? I'm unaware of that. That would turn me significantly
against Hassan on that front. I already had foreign policy questions,
but if he's if he's really against NATO, and that's true, then
I've never heard these talking points. That's the thing, Semaphore,
is for a long time I was the preeminent anti-Hassan scholar,
okay? In a lot of
So when people say he said something, I normally know. If I don't
If I don't know, he flirts with it. Okay.
No, I've Okay. Not equal to close. >> Wait, what What is
not equal to what? You are saying that his Hassan supported Cat
who is pro-NATO? Yeah, sure.
Answer the question. What is not equal to what? Answer So what
is the thing that's not equal to something else? >> Listen,
his support of Iran and the damage this is doing, which I don't
disagree with, is some His support of Iran Fetterman's support
of the Iran war? How equal to Hasan's fundamental view and desire
to dismantle America as the hegemon of the world. >> said
they were equal in what respect. They're not the same.
Do you not Do you not understand that this war is contributing
to the downfall of this country, your country?
As the global hegemon, more than anything Hasan has done in his
entire life or could possibly do. Like right now, in this moment,
John Fetterman is doing more to contribute to the downfall of
your country as the global hegemon than anything Hasan's capable
of. It's totally wild that you would play out this hypothetical,
where this guy, in reality, right now, in effect, is contributing
to that. And you go, "Oh, but technically, like I think possibly
Hasan could do this."
Not equal. One is worse, right? Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. In In terms of worseness, a his dead-ender position
that America's a great empire, the great Satan, whatever you
want to say, that belief, what action are you expecting that
is equal and comparable to what's going on with the Iran war?
He literally tried to make He would try to >> Ask Answer
the question. Answer. He would literally He would literally try
to make He would literally try to make Iran like a strategic
strategic partner, bro. He would try to become allies Like Obama.
Like Obama. Like Obama. I mean like an actual strategic partner.
I mean like no, I mean like someone He supports Iran. Do you
understand? He supports Iran. Dude. Dude. What's Dude. These
people are so propagandized. It's so [__] funny.
It's just so [__] funny, man.
They're totally propagandized. There's just no You could never
make this argument. And Pisco's going to try to be nice, but
unfortunately, we've reached the point where these people are
all embarrassing, right? They're totally
And Pisco has to be the adult in the room. Pisco is trying to
have a career past the next like year or two, okay?
He's the only one thinking that way. He's the only one who's
thinking, "Yeah, I need a career in a year or 2 years." He's
not thinking like right now, what gets me the most money or most
donations or most support,
Dude, it's
crazy.
He just become allies with Iran. He Yeah, he totally be like,
"Yeah, Iran, do you want more missiles? Do you want more Do you
want more components? Do you want F-35s? Hey Iran, do you want
For sure. He's Iran has
bro like terrorist organization because they're the resistance.
Is that really the same consequentially as this guy's doing a
bad policy that will make America weaker on a stage versus I
fundamentally believe America should ally itself with terrorist
groups and also like dismantle all of its reach across the country
for
So, question for Soy Boy here. And maybe we could talk about
it at some point.
Question for Soy Boy would be Do you believe Hassan's support
for the Houthis comes from a genuine love of the fact that the
Houthis do child slavery? A genuine love of the fact that they
basically hold their population
like
hostage in so many ways to resist like Saudi occupation of their
country.
Do you Do you like Do you think he really loves all the negatives
about the Houthis? Or do you think it mostly comes down to one
issue that as president he would have a lot of leeway to help
Do you think he loves the Houthis because of like Do you think
he'd want to partner with them and say these values represent
us? We should be partners with them. Do you sincerely believe
that?
Do you Do you actually believe that? Cuz I don't understand how
you could be so propagandized that you would think that it's
it's all about Oh, well, they're terrorists. They kill people
who are pro-America. Therefore, Hassan supports them. Therefore,
if Hassan's president, he would he would want to ally with the
Houthis. It's like so
I mean, I'm just trying to explain the worldview or think of
the worldview coherently like in my head and how it would be
how it would be unfolded if he became president. And this seems
totally incoherent to me. Seems like totally broken to me. For
better or for worse. Like these these are not equal things. And
if you think one is worse, the unless the argument you're giving
is he couldn't do it, which is I don't think a very strong argument,
I think obviously you you are picking Fetterman over this. >> He
couldn't do what? He couldn't do what? You know, I mean unilaterally
pull out of NATO, right? >> He couldn't do what? Joe Biden
introduced legislation that is preventing Trump to an extent
from doing this, right? So like if your argument is, well, he
couldn't do it, so it's okay that he believes that, I don't think
so. Oh, okay. Soy pill. I said it was okay that Hassan believes
that it's good to pull out of NATO. I said that, right? >> No,
I I didn't say that. I So I didn't say that, right? I didn't
say you said that. And I didn't suggest it, either. I didn't
say that you suggested it. I said No, you you just said, so it's
good, so it's okay. You just said so it's okay.
You think you think that I have to believe that it's okay that
I can't believe what Fetterman is doing. I don't think you think
I can't believe Hutch got away with making that argument. Now
Soy pill's arguing it for him. That's That's what's crazy to
me.
it's good. I think that you think that he couldn't accomplish
this, therefore it's somehow isn't as bad, and you'd pick him
over, right?
Well, I think that makes logical sense. If you don't think that
he's going to be successful in an action If you don't think,
and I'm not so confident that I don't think that would I don't
think that should be the deciding factor as to whether or not
you allow this person to have executive power. Wait, Soy pill,
aren't you the big like the whole guardrails are failing guy?
Now you're saying the guardrails are No, no, no, no, I'm saying
that Peace Go is I'm saying that Peace Go is I'm saying I don't
trust the guardrails to hold to because like, oh, Hassan will
be, you know, kept in line. He won't break any norms. Like, we'll
we'll we'll check his power. I'm like, no, that. I'm not putting
this person in power. I'm not risking that. Fetterman would like
appoint some crazy conservative judge to the Supreme Court. No,
he would not. I don't think he would do that. He [__]
would. No, he would not do that. Why would he Why would he Like,
you understand that he So you guys are sweeping for Fetterman,
you realize that, right? You're sweeping for MAGA. That's what
you're doing. You like MAGA. You don't think MAGA is that bad.
There's a difference I wasn't convinced of that, Hutch, but now
I'm convinced that you don't think MAGA is that bad. Peace Go,
there's a difference between
Has Hassan said something like that? That that pro-Trump like
the thing leading Democrat Party is TDS. Has Hasan ever said
anything like that? between saying that, you know, that Fetterman
has taken some bad positions and like voted with Trump some of
the times or whatever. But the reality is he has voted with Democrats
like over 90% of the time. Like he does support Democratic Party
policies. I want him primary. I think he's a bad Democrat. I
think he's bad for the like party brand overall. I and I think
he's really unpopular and he's going to be primary. But that
doesn't mean that that doesn't mean that he's like literally
MAGA. He would appoint a conservative Supreme Court justice.
I don't understand like the basis to make that >> The The
guy is Okay. So what's more offensive to you? What's more offensive
to you? Him going out and trashing our party constantly. That's
John Fetterman. That's John Fetterman. And Hasan does that, too.
From the perspective No, no, so they're equal on that. It's worse
because Fetterman is an elected Democrat. He's within the caucus.
It ruins the caucus's ability to even negotiate.
How are they supposed to wield any authority when when members
of their caucus are going out and working explicitly against
them? If if influencers do it, if Nick Fuentes comes out and
says, "Trump, I'm not going to vote for him." That doesn't really
affect government. If let's say for the sake of Steve Scalise
comes out and goes, "Trump, I hate Trump. I'll always work against
him now." This guy. That affects the workings the workings of
It's like a way different thing. It's way more It's way more
consequential. I agree. And in some cases it's worse in that
he's he's downplaying So Fetterman is downplaying Trump, correct?
And Hasan is not? Sure. And critiquing Dems in a way that implicitly
defends Trump is particularly egregious. Obviously egregious.
Obviously worse in every way.
That you're going to critique Dems in a specific way to defend
Trump to protect Trump? Insane. Totally insane. That's Hasan
is downplaying Trump as well. Is that Can you answer that question?
That's one aspect of peace guy. That's one aspect >> can
you Hutch, Hutch answer. So is Fetterman downplaying Wait, so
Hutch, Hutch, I'm not going to Hutch, Hutch, Hutch, Hutch. So
Hutch, Hutch, Hutch, Hutch. So Hutch, Hutch, Hutch, Hutch. Hutch,
is it Hutch, is it the case that Fetterman downplays Maga? Yes
or no? Yes, at times. Yeah, I think so. I >> And he does
so more than Hassan, correct? Sure, yeah. I don't I don't know
if Hassan ever downplays Maga. But but but The question is who
who is like So so so in terms of the identification of the threat
to this country, in terms of what I think is the overall state
of the of the base, the Democratic base or what have you. I think
that um I but Pisco, I don't think Why are you laughing? Because
I don't think you're processing like fully processing that Hassan
[__] Wait, wait, wasn't hold on, hold on, hold on.
Wait, is
is Hutch going to say this is actually about, you know, personal
beliefs, what I think your personal beliefs are? I thought when
people are saying would you vote for Epstein, didn't Hutch say
show me his policies?
Show me his policies. Show me what policies he's doing. We get
to see John Fetterman and how he's approaching things in terms
of like enabling Maga to pass what?
Enabling Maga to get funding for this war. There was two or three
other things that Pisco pointed out, okay? That's like that's
really consequential in terms of figuring out what his policies
are, right? For me, for Hassan, like to for to argue this about
Hassan that he would do anything like that I it seems impossible.
There's just nothing there.
You you basically have to argue that the President of the United
States would undo democracy somehow overnight.
And I don't even think I believe that about Hassan that he's
like truly anti-democracy in every way, that he would become
president and like immediately end democracy. I just doesn't
seem likely. Legitimately thinks that America is the most evil
country that has ever existed. He's a Marxist-Leninist.
He's a
He in totality is like way worse than disco inferno. Fetterman,
yeah,
So, Hutch thinks that Hassan
just in terms of the hyperbole here, Hutch has to believe that
Hassan thinks America is worse than Nazi Germany.
That America
is worse than the Mongol Empire. That America is like like there
are other countries that have existed.
I I just don't see I don't think he makes his argument. >> is
siding with MAGA because he wants MAGA to win or he wants the
Democrats to do something different?
No, I think that he is MAGA light. I think that he wants
Why do people say things and they don't even think about how
this is going to be reversed and applied to the argument they're
making?
Would you say Hassan critiques America cuz he hates well, unfortunately
they've all been brainwashed or wants America to be better, right?
Hates America or wants America to be better. You're not if you're
not brainwashed, right? Yeah, I know that they keep asserting
that Hassan's an ML even though he's not. He's explicitly said
otherwise. But, okay. Jesus, man. >> wants aspects of MAGA
to win over. I don't think he he thinks that Trump is that bad
and I think that he wants Democrats to be more on on board with
MAGA actions. Okay, I
I disagree. I think he wants Democrats to win and do better.
Maybe to moderate a little bit. He feels they've gone too far
on some things, but I think it's nowhere near MAGA light. But,
but you're entitled to your opinion.
All right. >> we can go on and >> that that he you
think that he consciously thinks uh as he goes on his shows with
Mark Levin, this disgusting freak, and on these Fox News shows
with these disgusting MAGA freaks, that he's doing what's in
the best interest of the Democrats to win. That's your thought
process? I think he's in his heart he thinks he's helping the
Democratic Party by trying to correct them from going too far.
I I believe that. Yeah. I think he's a free rider. I think he's
disgusting and I think that he is abiding by this unconstitutional
there's so much more evidence for arguing that Fetterman is aligning
with Maga more and more every day. And there's no evidence for
what they're they're sorry, there's scant evidence in 8 hours
a day, 6 days a week
he finished my food. There's scant evidence that, you know, through
Hasan's entire catalog, 6 hours a 6 to 8 hours a 6 days a week
for years
that he's like an ML. There's like some things that sort of hint
in that direction, like three, four clips that could have hit
that could hit in that direction, and like a bunch that hit in
the other direction.
But they think that there's better evidence against Hasan, the
things they believe about Hasan, the things they're saying about
Hasan, than there is against Fetterman basically being like a
pseudo Maga light type of guy right now. I I don't get it. Uh
terrorist threat of these Maga elitists um who are destroying
our country from within and without and making our country weaker.
>> Why doesn't he switch parties? I I think you can make
a valid argument for that, Pisco. I I just disagree, but I think
you can make a valid argument.
answer that question. Like, why doesn't he Why doesn't he switch
to the
He stops He loves being independent. He loves He He loves being
the guy. He loves being the guy that the one good Democrat. These
people These enlightened centrists, Hasan, you understand this,
have a attraction and fetish to being this uh oh I say both sides.
I say both sides. You know it's It's the Chris Cuomos of the
world. It's Stephen A. Smith. It's all these [__]
They get their hard being the one guy who calls out their own
side. That's why. Who replaced Who replaced Pisco with somebody
awesome. What the This is crazy.
Who replaced Who replaced Pisco with somebody totally awesome
today. Holy sh
He would never say this before. Where did this come from? This
is like a totally new Pisco. centrists, Hasan, you understand
this, have a attraction and fetish to being this uh oh I say
both sides. I say both sides. You know it's It's the Chris Cuomos
of the world. It's Stephen A. Smith. It's all these They get
their card being the one guy who calls out their own side. That's
why. You know what gets my legitimate
That's what gets me hard. Wait, what did you say? It's good to
have you back,
Okay, hold on. Seeing you fired up. Let's go. Hutch By the way,
hold on. Hold on. When I I can go back to the footage of today,
okay? We watched this clip a clip about this when they first
started this argument.
And I'm not even kidding you, I said, by the way, it was like
the first 30 seconds. So, like 10 minutes 15 minutes before this
in the argument, okay? I said, "Hutch is a brat in a BDSM relationship
and he is trying to get Pisco to slap him around right now."
That's what That was my reaction to Hutch saying this stupid
thing about, "Well, at least Israel's our ally." I was like,
"Dude, he is trying to get slapped around right now. That's what
it is." And absolutely, he just said, "You know what gets my
card seeing you fired
Ladies and gentlemen,
we got him. We got him. We got him, okay?
Easy. Back to this. >> move on from this cuz we got like
10 minutes left and we haven't talked about the birthright citizenship
case and that's a Pisco's Oh, yeah. Did you guys >> That's
my jam. That's my jelly. Yeah, resting this entire case on the
idea that domicile is like the one determining factor and not
just a like an additive here is kind of ridiculous. So much so
that the ACLU lawyer was like almost trying to argue with him
until uh was it Ketanji Brown Jackson like it's like clarified
or maybe it was Sotomayor or was like, "No, no, I think he's
actually agreeing with your point that domicile here is clearly
not the distinguishing factor as to whether or not you need it
to be a uh citizen." And so, this I think that was just such
a >> embarrassment for that Trump lawyer. That was >> Spike
Bell, would you say that there would you say that that the Supreme
Court is actually a pretty important guardrail and that it is
meaningfully constraining this administration? Yeah, I don't
think it's completely 100% capitulated to Trump, but once you
make the immunity case, uh I think uh a lot you got to lose a
lot of will from me. I just think that this is like another example
of this administration just being like being really impotent
in a lot of ways. I think it's a pathetic administration and
a lot of the rhetoric that I hear about the administration is
that he's like all powerful and I just keep seeing the system
check him over and over and over again.
Like I want to I also want to ask Pesca if he like did you did
you look at the executive order that he did with respect to mail
in ballots or whatever and do you anticipate that that's going
to survive judicial review?
I don't think that it will be upheld by by the courts. So I did
a little desire segment on it. So let's start first with
the birth certificate issue. I think that it went very poorly
for the Okay. So
and some of the most it probably did go poorly for the administration.
I'm probably going to pull out here. This is this is good stuff.
Very awesome hutch screen cap right at the end here. Don't know
how we paused perfectly in this frame. That could happen to anybody.
That's just like half eyes closed. I'm not going to it's not
it's not like a hutch face. It's just very funny looking. Very
funny looking.
Something like that. Okay.
very goofy.